ja es ist eigentlich ganz einfach man
muss ja genau erklären was das du geht
und dann würden sie die Leute freiwillig
die was heute da ist gern haben dass sie
einmal ein bisschen gewöhnen und gerne
in der Natur sein und da haben sie 25
gleich mit wir haben dann nochmal
gemacht und dann sehe gleich aus der
kristallisiert wer das zeigt er zu holen
und dann hat sie das weggeben
in der Natur und und ich gehe ganz gerne
meine Grenzen und das war
Herausforderungen und die wollte
unbedingt
perfekt gemacht da hat der Erfahrung
wenn man das macht der ist mit ins
Konverter nachher genau
beim motiviert dass man unsere Grenzen
kennt und so ist es möglich sein dass
man bei dem Bewerb mit und dann macht ja
also jeder hat sich gegenseitig voll
gepusht hat einen anderen motiviert also
das letzte Jahrhundert und dann hat es
super funktioniert und kann auch
irgendwie aufgeben oder doch lassen
und ähm deswegen also Muskelkater habe
ich natürlich meine vier Stunden aber es
geht
hier oben wir haben viel schöne Berge
haben wir verschiedene Berge aufgegangen
es war schon anstrengend da und aber
schwierigste Erlebnis war auf jeden Fall
am ersten Tag ganz zum Schluss wenn man
dann nur die ganze das ganze Biwak
zurück Offizieren muss mit der Ute
körperlich schon am Ende gewesen aber
wenn man dann ins Ziel eingerufen ist
dann warte mal alle Glücksgefühle
verändern